Good morning Hank; it’s Wednesday, May 18th,
2011, also known as Button Your Button Day.
Hank, in the last 24 hours I finished the
big revision of my novel and I also watched
your poetic commencement address, and it made
me think a lot about education and why we’re
alive and stuff.
Right, so when we think about education we
often think about a soft/hard continuum. On
the far edge of hard, you have mathematics
which, you know, there’s only one right
answer, and everything’s about numbers and
data. And then on the far edge of the soft
side you have the study of literature, where
everything’s about, you know, what it means
to be a person in a world full of other people
and how to understand ourselves in history
and all that boring stuff.
You know what I’m talking about, Hank: history’s
pretty soft, physics is pretty hard, biology
is somewhere in the middle because, you know,
it involves adorable baby pigs but they’re
dead and you have to dissect them. Psychology
thinks that it’s hard but it’s actually
soft; economics thinks that it’s soft but
it’s actually hard, you know what I’m
talking about!
Right, except in my opinion, Hank, that continuum
is complete and utter... Warner Chilcott.
So Hank, when you study mathematics, you’re
really studying two things: first you’re
studying mathematical language. So the simplest
kind of mathematical language is that when
we talk about the number seven we’re not
only talking about seven donuts or seven pairs
of pants, we’re talking about the abstracted
idea of seven. And then when you get to algebra,
the language of mathematics suddenly involves
letters. And the language of math gets more
and more complex as you learn, which is why,
when I read something by Brotherhood 2.0 Resident
Mathematician Daniel Biss, I feel illiterate.
So that’s the first thing you’re doing
when you study math. The second thing is that
you’re attempting to understand the universe,
right? I mean, I don’t want to overstate
the matter, but that’s basically what we’re
doing. Ultimately, the reason that we have
to know that the square root of four is two
is because it helps us to build cathedrals
and think about space and make out with people,
but more on that in a second.
Right, so we study math for the twin reasons
of wanting to learn mathematical language
and wanting to understand our place in the
universe, which turns out to be precisely
why we also study literature: to learn about
language and to understand our place in the
universe. Which by the way, Hank, gets to
the thing that make me angriest in the entire
world, which is when people say that there
is only one right answer in math, but that
every answer is equally correct in literature.
That’s just bunk!
First off, there is often more than one correct
answer in math, and secondly NOT EVERY ANSWER
IS EQUALLY CORRECT IN LITERATURE! I am a giant
squid of anger!
For instance, Hank, if you think that The
Adventures of Huckleberry Finn is a pro-slavery
novel, you’re wrong! You’re as wrong as
you are if you think that the square root
of four is strawberries!
Right, so students of the world, I want you
to look at me for a second. Most of the questions
that you’re asking in your literature classes
are not that interesting. Like the question
of whether the author intended that symbol
or that metaphor- let me tell you, as an author
who intends symbols and metaphors- that question
is not interesting.
It doesn’t matter if, when I was writing
Paper Towns, I wanted the Great White Wall
of Cow to reference the Great White Wall of
Whale in Moby Dick. The Great White Wall of
Cow and/or Whale isn’t there for you to
think about authorial intent, it’s there
for you to think about nature’s seemingly
absolute apathy toward individual humans and
what the heroic response to that apathy is.
And the reason that reading critically, like
reading for theme and metaphor and symbol
is important is because those things are ways
in to the big, interesting questions, many
of which are same questions that math is trying
to answer.
Hank, the vast majority of us imagine ourselves
as like literature people or else as like
math people. But the truth is that the massive
parallel processor known as the human brain
is neither a literature organ or a math organ.
It is both and more.
Hank, putting aside learning for learning’s
sake, I’d argue that understanding the universe
and its inhabitants is helpful in pretty much
every human endeavor, which is why nerds,
in my experience, are more likely to understand
special relativity and also more likely to
be good at kissing.
So math people, let me tell you that imaginary
stories can be every bit as intellectually
engaging as imaginary numbers. And literature
people, I am here to tell you that set theory
is every bit as fascinating and moving and
beautiful as the Great Gatsby.
Hank, I’ll see you on Monday. Is it Friday?
No, it’s Wednesday, isn’t it. Hank, I’ll
see you on Friday. God, I’m so bad at days!
But really Hank, are days of the week math
or literature? They’re both.